Prof: Okay everyone.
First, thank you for coming out
on such a blustery day.
If you have not picked up your
exam from your teaching fellow,
you can do that after class
today.
And we're switching gears.
We're moving from questions
about how to manage chemicals in
the environment to questions
about how to affect
conservation.
And also especially how to
allocate and manage land use and
various natural resources
associated with landscapes.
And today I'm going to use an
example,
a history of a conservation
effort in New York State known
as the Adirondack Park that has
a conservation history that now
spans almost 130 years.
One of the oldest parks in the
nation,
and it contains many terrific
examples of a variety of
different strategies to conserve
resources and to protect the
land.
Now, no matter where you are in
the world,
and if you're interested in
managing land use and managing
ecosystems or biological
resources,
there are a variety of
questions that I'd encourage you
to ask.
One is first to become familiar
with property rights.
How are they defined?
Who has rights to which types
of resources?
And in this case,
it'll become clear that it's
important for you to think about
property not as a thing but as a
set of social relationships.
Property is often defined in
law as a bundle,
a bundle of rights.
But if I have a right that's
defined and protected by law,
then others have an obligation.
So you can't really think about
rights in the absence of
consideration of obligations.
And if you violate your
obligation,
the concept behind a property
right is that the state or some
level of government will have
the capacity to monitor,
to discover the defect,
to enforce sanctions.
So a second question that you
need to consider is what is the
appropriate level of government
to institute protective policy?
Should local governments have
this ability?
Often they don't,
because they have other
obligations and their financial
background is quiet slight in
comparison to state governments
or the federal government.
So thinking about the
particular nature of a problem,
whether it crosses especially
political boundaries.
So many watersheds,
as an example,
cross political boundaries:
they cross town boundaries,
they cross state boundaries.
Many water bodies provide the
boundary between political
jurisdictions as well as nation
states.
So thinking about the
appropriate level of government
to the kind of problem you're
interested in managing is a
really important task.
How about participation in
decision making?
As you think about conservation
strategies, what should be the
role of the public in
participating in the type of
strategy that's chosen?
And you might think of a tract
of land that everybody feels is
very special,
perhaps because it has
endangered species,
perhaps because of its open
space character,
perhaps its wildness.
You might think of a variety of
different strategies to protect
that if it's currently in
private ownership.
And one of those would be land
acquisition on the part of the
government.
So many national parks,
for example,
particularly in the Eastern
United States,
have been created through the
process of land acquisition and
in some instances,
the exercise of eminent domain.
And we'll talk about eminent
domain,
where the government uses its
authority to acquire property
for public purposes virtually by
taking it away from the private
owner but providing
compensation.
Intensity of regulation.
Regulation is another strategy.
So you might simply adopt rules
that govern density of allowable
new development or the type of
new development,
whether it's residential,
commercial,
agricultural, industrial.
And this is the origin of the
idea of zoning,
land use segregation,
land use density control,
and often associated
subdivision regulations,
which are very specific and
detail how development has to
proceed,
including lot sizes,
shoreline access requirements--
a variety of different
restrictions are associated with
subdivision regulations.
How about the legitimacy of
public value?
If you create a really tough
set of land use regulations and
the property owners do not
believe in the legitimacy of the
regulation,
it guarantees that you're going
to have noncompliance.
And noncompliance means that
you're going to have extensive
surveillance and monitoring
costs and enforcement costs.
So believing in the legitimacy
of the public value is
important.
Often an educational process
has to take place in order for
people to understand why
regulations are occurring.
And in many cases,
they're developed and adopted
to prevent damage,
the damage that might be
induced by one property owner on
an adjacent private owner.
So the idea of deciding that
you want to build a casino on
your property--your neighbors
might object to that.
Or perhaps a nightclub,
so that there are a variety of
different land uses that
threaten other landowners in the
vicinity.
Property value often rises
following conservation efforts.
So the establishment of a park
is very commonly followed by
adjacent land values increasing
quite dramatically,
and I'll provide you with a
couple of examples of that.
Density restrictions,
land use segregation,
aesthetics.
Increasingly over the past
half-century we've seen zoning
ordinances being used for the
purpose of controlling
aesthetics.
So aesthetics might be managed
by specifying density
guidelines, requiring larger and
larger lot sizes.
So in parts of the California
coastal area,
for example,
there are zoning ordinances
that demand a hundred acres
before a new house might be
constructed.
This is to preserve the open
space character of the area.
So thinking about how you
define a desirable or an ideal
aesthetic that would be your
objective is a pretty difficult
thing to do.
The Forest Service started
pioneering research into the
question of what types of
landscapes do people prefer.
And they were doing this
because they were getting
increasingly taken to court
because of perceived esthetic
damage associated with clear
cuts,
particularly clear cuts that
were visible because of timber
leases they had allocated.
But they would be visible from
nearby wilderness areas.
So they decided that they would
establish a variety of social
experiments,
where they would test people's
preferences for different kinds
of landscapes,
ranging from the wild to the
fully domesticated agricultural
to intense urban centers.
You might be interested in the
results.
And following new regulation,
when does the government have
the obligation to compensate?
So supposing I'm a private land
owner and I have fifty acres of
land,
and you develop a new zoning
ordinance that tells me that I
have to have twenty-five acres
before I can build a new house.
So that tells me I basically
have two building lots.
Well I thought that I would
have, prior to that regulation,
perhaps fifty building lots
that might be one acre in size.
So my expectation has been
suddenly changed by the passage
of law, and my property value
would significantly diminish.
So under what situations does
the government need to
compensate the private land
owner for regulatory activity?
Now I'd like to drop you down
onto the case of the
Adirondacks.
But first, I'd like you to
think about the distribution of
public land in the United
States.
So out of several hundred
million acres of land that are
currently under the jurisdiction
of the National Park Service or
the Forest Service or the Bureau
of Land Management or the Bureau
of Reclamation,
the majority of these lands are
located in the Western United
States,
particularly in the mountain
arid region.
If you look at the eastern part
of the United States,
you can't see this too clearly
because of the light that's on
up here.
I don't know,
Judith, if it's possible to
diminish that at all.
But as you move toward northern
New England, you might be able
to make out a patch of landscape
right up in this area,
and that's the Adirondack Park.
It's one of the largest intact
forests that we've got in the
eastern United States,
actually one of the largest
intact forests that we've got in
the lower forty-eight states.
And it also is adjacent to
Vermont, which is adjacent to
New Hampshire and Maine.
And together,
these are clustered and form
what is now thought of as the
Northern Forest in the eastern
part of the country.
And the Adirondacks,
within this zone,
has the longest history of
protection.
But there are the Green
Mountains and there's the Green
Mountain National Forest,
and there are the White
Mountains in adjacent New
Hampshire that spill over into
Maine.
So there's really quite an
unusual tract of land that has a
long and curious conservation
history.
Again, a bit of a closer look
at the Adirondacks.
Now as you look out across this
landscape, you might think of it
as wild and natural.
But in reality,
it's the location of intense
conflicts over competing
interest groups about how they
might best gain access to public
lands.
This is the Adirondack Forest
Preserve, protected since the
1880s.
If you look back at the history
of conservation effort in the
nation,
Yosemite was deeded to
California in 1864,
Yellowstone--Yellowstone
National Park,
was created in 1872,
and Adirondack Forest Preserve
was created in 1885.
It was transformed into a park
a few years later,
and in 1895,
the New York State Legislature
passed a Constitutional
amendment so that lands that are
designated as Forest Reserve
lands,
are now called Forest Preserve
lands.
They are forever protected by
the Constitution of New York
State.
So that that means that two
successive Legislatures need to
enact a statute that would allow
them to be transferred out of
that category.
So this is a very rigorous
standard that is hard to change.
And by the way,
there are different kinds of
laws that might be applied,
such as the executive order by
William Clinton that created the
largest tract of wilderness by
relying on federally owned but
non-wilderness lands up in
Alaska,
just before he left office.
So you could use a federal
executive order to accomplish
wilderness designation.
Or the Forest Service or the
Parks Service or the Bureau of
Land Management,
they could also
administratively designate
tracts of land as being
wilderness that are under their
jurisdiction.
So that in terms of the gold
standard of offering the
greatest amount of protection,
you would want a designation
that would be very difficult to
change.
And New York State and the
legislature I think got it right
back in the 1890s when they
created the Forest Reserve.
Jumping ahead,
the Wilderness Statute in the
United States wasn't adopted
until 1864.
And then in 1968,
the Adirondack National Park
was proposed by a variety of
individuals in New York State.
And this upset people in the
Adirondacks quite a bit,
because they were worried about
losing control.
They were concerned about
losing their authority,
their ability to effect policy
within their park,
within the state.
And this prompted the
Legislature to move ahead by
1971 and create the Adirondack
Park Agency.
Then by 1973,
the Adirondack Park Agency Land
Use Plan and Regulation went
into effect.
And this really will be the
topic of the discussion today.
Thinking about the forces that
lay behind the development of
the statute, you might consider
the Erie Canal.
The Erie Canal runs from the
eastern side of New York all the
way to the western edge.
And when the timber resources
in the park were poorly managed,
when the tops of trees were
left on the ground and they
dried out, they would burn.
And forest fires in the 1860s,
'70s, and '80s,
were really common in response
to these mismanaged forest lands
drying out.
So what happens when a tract of
forest burns?
It basically loses its flood
storage capacity,
the organic matter in the soil
often is released,
it breaks down.
So that water running off the
landscape commonly floods,
so you can get a burst into the
rivers and through the Erie
Canal, and then you get drought.
So that if New York State was
going to insure that commerce
could move westward,
it had to ensure a more
sustainable form of forest
management in the park.
Now also, think about what was
happening in the middle of the
nineteenth century.
There were several movements in
literature and art and also in
ecology that are quite curious,
and they were colliding in a
way that really provided impetus
for the creation of parks and
protected areas.
And one strain of thought,
known as transcendentalism,
that you can discover in the
writings of Samuel Taylor
Coleridge,
Shelley, Keats,
William Wordsworth,
Emerson, Whitman,
and Thoreau,
and particularly Emerson's
essay on nature,
caused people to think very
differently about nature and
what it was and its importance
to the human condition.
So that nature to Emerson was
an organism,
a symbol of the mind,
it was a moral educator,
a source of spiritual truth,
and a resource for the
imagination.
Now at the same time George
Perkins Marsh was writing,
and he produced a book called
Man and Nature,
talking about the destruction
of forests and how that might
lead to the decline of
civilizations.
Quite curious,
the writings in the latter part
of the nineteenth century
presaged the loss of biological
diversity,
as well as climate change that
we're now experiencing.
So he wrote,
back in 1864:
"A condition of
impoverished productiveness,
of shattered surface,
of climactic excess as to
threaten deprivation,
barbarism, and even extinction
of species."
So nearly a century and a half
ago,
a scientist was predicting
climate change associated with
the way that we were mismanaging
resources and the landscape.
Also the targets of
transcendentalists include
Christian views.
They challenged the human role
to be one of dominating nature,
the Christian view that we
should be fruitful and multiply
and replenish the earth and
subdue it,
and that Christianity denies
souls to non-human species.
These were new and very
interesting thoughts to people.
This is captured in a work
produced by Roderick Nash,
Wilderness and the American
Mind,
that's published by Yale Press
that I commend to you if you're
interested in following the way
that these ideas collided.
Now at the same time,
there were many artists that
were painting landscapes both in
the western part of the nation
as well as in the east,
including Thomas Cole and
Albert Bierstadt,
Winslow Homer,
and Frederic Church.
And they all painted in the
Adirondacks.
So think about the fact that
people were reading the
transcendentalist literature at
the same time that these art
shows were traveling around not
just the United States but
traveling around the world,
giving people a very different
impression of what it was like
in the more remote parts of the
United States.
So Winslow Homer has painted
more in the Adirondacks than the
others,
so I just thought I'd show you
his work on Two Guides,
the Hunter, and the Fisherman,
basically celebrating the
experience of being the
outdoors.
I'm going to fast forward on
you to the middle part of the
twentieth century,
when you recall that I argued
that the interstate highway
system was built largely in
response to concerns about the
Cold War.
But this network eventually
ringed the Adirondack Park and
it made it accessible by the
early 1960s to more than ten
million people within a day's
drive.
So access is really a critical
determinant of property value
and also the rate of
development.
By the 1960s,
mid-sixties and 1970s,
increasing leisurely time,
increasing demand for
recreational opportunities led
to increasing property values
within the Adirondacks.
People were looking for second
homes.
The development industry was
booming not just here but also
in the vicinity of Bar Harbor in
Maine and the vicinity of Grand
Teton in Jackson,
Wyoming, also in the Sierras,
so that the population in the
United States wanted access to
remote recreational
opportunities.
There was a real interest in
wildness and nature,
particularly in the concept of
wilderness.
And quite honestly,
I'm surprised at your
generation.
I don't see the same interest
in wildness or wilderness that
was very prominent in people's
concerns about conservation back
in the 1970s.
So that many in the Legislature
in New York became concerned
about development being financed
with international capital in
the park,
rapid cutting of the forest,
rapid development--
particularly along
shorelines--and rapid increases
in property value.
In some communities,
communities that had
populations of only 300 people,
new projects were proposed up
to 10,000 new units in size.
If you then extrapolate that
one new housing unit might house
on average two to three people,
this could multiply the
population of a community by ten
or even twenty times.
So what would that mean for
that community?
What would it mean in terms of
its need to invest in
institutional support for the
community?
And by that what do I mean?
Well how about road
development, highway
development, school systems,
fire, police?
So that economic pressure was
being brought to bear on these
communities that already were
the most impoverished in New
York State.
That band of forest that I
pointed out to you in northern
New England is demographically
quite interesting.
It's grown to be bimodal in
terms of income distribution and
dominated more heavily by the
poorest.
But also, there are increasing
numbers of private property
owners who own second homes.
But they don't vote there,
they don't vote in the
Adirondacks and many of them
don't vote in New York State.
So that this bimodal
distribution creates a very
interesting political dynamic,
a tension between those that
have always lived there that are
poor,
as opposed to those that have
the capacity to buy the new
houses and bring their
conservation values to the
Adirondacks.
So this statute was really
unusual.
And the preamble to the statute
includes this language:
"Local governments in the
Adirondack Park find it
increasingly difficult to cope
with the unrelenting pressures
for development being brought to
bear on the area and exercise
their discretionary powers to
create an effective land use and
development control
framework."
Now, the mission statement of
this law is really quite
complex: "The basic purpose
of this article is to ensure
optimum overall conservation,
protection, preservation,
development and use of the
unique scenic,
esthetic, wildlife,
recreational,
open space,
historic, ecological,
and natural resources of the
Adirondack Park."
So within this mission
statement, you should
immediately see a number of
potential conflicts.
How can you at once maximize
conservation at the same time
you're maximizing development
and use?
Actually, it's interesting.
If you drive into a national
forest, you'll see a sign beside
the edge of the road when you
enter all national forests.
And the sign will say
"Land of Many Uses."
Land of many uses,
well how do you reconcile
multiple uses within one tract
of land managed by a public
agency?
Well, it's difficult at best,
and that's largely part of the
story today.
Innovative requirements in this
statute demanded an ecological
analysis.
So what is the resiliency of
different ecological zones?
Different ecosystems?
How much development can they
sustain, and is there a logic
behind allocating a density
requirement to different types
of ecosystems?
How about density regulations
and the clustering concept?
This statute relied on the idea
that you should concentrate new
development in close proximity
to village centers so that you
don't overstress the local
government's need to develop new
roads,
to maintain those roads,
and also require new power
lines,
new sewage lines,
new water lines.
So the idea that cluster
development builds on existing
centers of the population is
really quite interesting.
And this was to protect the
open space character as well as
the ecological characteristics
of the surrounding landscape.
It wasn't designed really to
conserve energy.
But if I were going to
challenge you to design today a
land use regulatory scheme that
would be the most conserving of
energy resources,
it probably would follow this
model and it would follow the
model because if you have people
living closer together,
you are clearly not going to
use as much fuel moving around
between shopping and recreation
and school and other activities.
So if you increase the density
restriction,
you increase the amount of land
area required before a new house
might be developed between the
village centers,
then that would discourage
development in those areas.
And in the case of the park,
inside the centers there is no
density restriction at all.
So it's an encouragement
basically to build up between
the village centers.
In the more remote areas,
there's a requirement that you
have forty-two acres before a
new house can be built.
Forty-two acres is a lot of
land.
Forty-two acres in Connecticut,
most of Connecticut is zoned on
average one acre per new unit.
So forty-two units might be
placed on that zone.
But only one could be placed on
that area within the
Adirondacks.
It also required setback
requirements.
Setback requirements,
setback requirements from
especially water bodies,
streams and lakeshores.
And this wild-to-urban
continuum was designed really
with an aesthetic purpose,
to try to protect the park-like
character of the area.
It also had a provision that
was really new back in the 1970s
to offer specific protection for
agricultural lands.
So that agricultural lands were
thought of not the way that we
would think of them today,
as providing an opportunity for
locally-grown produce that would
be more energy efficient.
But they were designed
predominately to protect the
open space character of the
park.
Vista preservation so that
individual vistas were
identified.
Actually, that's kind of an
interesting sidelight story
about how that occurred.
One might think that there
really might not be a legally
defensible means of going out
and identifying what the most
beautiful areas are in an area
this large.
So the Adirondacks is roughly
six million acres in size.
It's larger than Yosemite,
Yellowstone,
and Glacier National Parks put
together.
So that wandering around and
trying to figure out where the
ideal vistas are located was a
challenge that the park agency
had to confront.
They were required to do that
by statute.
The reality of how they did it
is that an engineer and a
surveyor got into a pickup truck
with a case of beer and drove
around for a weekend looking for
what they thought were pretty
landscapes.
They put pins in a map,
and lo and behold,
these pinholes in the maps
translated into legally binding
regulations that prevented
development of different forms
in the vicinity of the scenic
vista.
Wetlands in wild and scenic and
recreational rivers were also
designated.
The definition of a wetland is
actually quite interesting and
quite difficult.
Today as I was coming in to
give the lecture,
I noticed that areas that
normally look dry had standing
water on them.
So that low-lying areas can be
quite deceptive if you're not
there during extreme rain
events.
So that wetland designation
gave the Adirondack Park Agency
jurisdiction to deny
development.
People were not allowed to
build in wetlands,
period.
Now most states have wetlands
laws as well,
not just in the Adirondacks.
Most states do not have wild,
scenic, and recreational river
statutes that provide an overlay
on top of the Adirondack Park
Agency statute.
Finally, the provision that
stirred terrific controversy was
that the zoning authority that
previously was held by local
governments was overtaken by the
state government.
So not only would you have
private property owners that
would be highly resistant to
this new set of very complicated
regulations that they viewed
actually took away their private
property rights and diminished
their property value,
but they also had local
governments that felt that they
were being pushed out of the
picture,
that their zoning
responsibility that they'd had
for more than a hundred years,
that that was taken away from
them.
So that the statute set up
class A projects,
which were large development
projects that might have more of
a regional influence.
And those were reviewed by the
state.
And class B projects were
reviewed by local governments
but only if the local
governments adopted the state
standards to apply to those
projects.
So if you were given the
responsibility to develop an
ecologically grounded approach
to land use regulation,
what would you do?
Well, you probably would go off
and conduct an inventory of what
resources are there in the park.
You'd look for aquifers;
you'd map them out.
You'd map out surface waters
and you'd map out setback
distances from those surface
waters to try to be sure to
protect water quality.
You'd take a look surficial
geology, particularly areas that
had shallow soils or soils that
had clay beneath it.
Adirondacks is rather famous
for its clay,
which means that you have a
clay, impervious surface that is
often only one or two feet
beneath the top of the
landscape.
That means that if you're going
to put in a septic system--
and a septic system basically
means that human sewage from a
facility or a house goes down
into a pipe,
it goes into a holding tank
where solids settle out,
and then fluid drains off and
it leaches out through pipes
that have holes in the bottom of
them and then down through a bed
of sand--
but if there is a clay area
that lies beneath the sand,
that means that the sewage is
going to stay close to the
surface,
it's not going to dissipate,
it's not going to break down,
and it means that bacterial
contamination of surface water
supplies is much more probable.
General soils characteristics
were also mapped.
Elevation was mapped,
and I'll tell you more about
that in just a second,
as well as land use.
Where are the residential areas?
So that the idea of clustering
development in close proximity
to where existing development
was was a critical way of
thinking about this.
Now, land cover also was
considered,
so whether or not the tract of
land was forested,
whether or not it was
heathland, whether or not it was
wetland.
So that the biological
resources were also mapped.
On top of where did the state
lands lie.
So there are 107 towns and
villages in the Adirondack Park.
So 107 different local
governments that were upset with
the State of New York for taking
their authority away,
but they all had to go through
this mapping process.
So those of you that are
familiar with geographic
information systems know that
this process now goes on
electronically.
So soils and vegetation and
land use and property ownership
patterns,
they're all piled on top of one
another electronically so you
can zoom in or you could change
the layers that you're looking
at instantly.
In this case,
they drew these maps out by
hand,
and that actually led to some
pretty interesting problems when
private landowners would come to
the government and say,
"You know,
I'm not certain what zone I'm
in.
I appear to be on a
boundary."
And it turned out that by
drawing a line on a map that is
really small in scale that the
width of the line itself was a
hundred yards wide.
And a hundred yards may or may
not include all the property of
an individual.
So which section would they lie
within?
The forty-two acre zone or
perhaps the three-point-two acre
zone?
It made a huge difference in
the eventual salability and
property value of the area.
And also proximity to roads:
I mean, if you think about an
area, you would also want to
know where the road network was.
You would think very carefully
about how you would allocate
density based upon access to
roadways.
So all of this information was
put together to develop this
map, which is a legal
instrument.
The idea that a map might be a
legal instrument is kind of an
interesting thought.
So that in order for someone to
know what their rights are,
their property rights are,
they would have to pinpoint
themselves on this map.
And each color is associated
with a certain density
allowance.
So if you are located in the
green, that means that you need
forty-two acres in order to
develop a new house.
If you're located in the
yellow, that's eight acres.
If you're located in the red,
then you only need one acre.
And if you're located in the
village centers that's
designated as brown,
you have no density requirement
at all.
By the way, you've heard about
cap and trade.
Well the cap and trade idea can
be applied very well to a
situation like this.
So that you might allow trading
rights under certain
circumstances within a
designated boundary perhaps
within a community.
So that the idea of
transferable development rights
is something that we'll talk
about next week.
So these are the different
zoning limits that have been
established by law and have
governed the Adirondack Park
Agency's implementation of this
plan for quite a while.
How does this play out as
you're looking at a landscape?
Well here is a little
community, it's a community of
Keene Valley that is just at the
foot of the high peaks region,
the highest mountains in New
York State.
And this is a community of
about 800 people.
And here is the village center
with no density requirements.
And as you move away from the
village center,
you find that you're required
to have larger and larger lots
before you can build a new
structure,
until you reach the public
lands, which begin in this case
up on these hillsides leading up
into the high peaks.
So that you can think about
this as a kind of a set of
concentric circles.
It's much more complicated than
just concentric circles,
but development ranging from
the urban center on one hand to
wilderness areas that are
designated on the other hand.
So that the public lands have
their own set of regulations
under this statute.
The village of Lake Placid,
where the Olympic Games were
held, provides a good example of
this.
Where you see the brown in the
center is the area where there
are no density requirements.
And then the lands that border
the federal wilderness areas
designated by this blue,
they have the higher
restrictions,
the requirements for larger
acreages.
So where are battlegrounds?
Where would you imagine you
would get the most litigation?
Where would you find the
greatest amount of private
conflict over these regulations?
Well one clearly would be areas
with views.
So areas that have high
elevations or areas that are
adjacent to water bodies.
So if you were going to map out
property values,
you find that areas that had
the best views,
that had the highest elevation,
and that were adjacent to
either rivers or lakes or ponds
would have the highest property
values.
So you could be predictive
about this, about where you're
going to receive your greatest
amount of conflict and
resistance to new regulation.
When property values are
highest, you'll find people are
most anxious to develop.
The rate of development occurs
more rapidly along roadways,
along lakes and rivers.
The cost of developing in the
mountainous areas at higher
elevation are more prohibitive
to developers.
So shorelines,
such as this example on
lakeshores are extremely
desirable from the perspective
of a developer--
multi-million dollar boathouses
that have been constructed.
Also, hotels and large camps on
islands.
There are more than 1,000
islands on Adirondack lakes and
ponds.
Here's one of them in Lake
George, as an example.
Lake George provides the water
supply for its town so that the
water is treated with chlorine,
like New Haven's water is.
It's filtered in a very rough
way through sand.
But it's not filtered by
activated carbon,
which could remove a variety of
different kinds of organic
pollutants that might be in the
water supply.
So in this situation,
if this facility had its own
leaching field,
we'd be worried about it,
because most of the islands in
the Adirondacks are basically
mounds of bedrock that have very
shallow soils on them,
that have very low capacity to
absorb human sewage,
so that there is considerable
conflict between the developers'
interest to build adjacent to
water bodies and the concern of
these communities to protect
their water supplies.
Another good example over prime
development land from the
perspective of the investor
would be a scenic vista such as
this.
This is one of the forty-odd
scenic vistas that have specific
development restrictions.
So that it sits just adjacent
to Mount Van Hoevenberg and
overlooks the Adirondack high
peaks.
And a developer,
McDonald's Corporation,
decided this was a site that
they wanted to put a McDonald's
up for when they preparing for
the Olympic Games.
They didn't want to go next to
Wendy's or to build their golden
arch next to a Burger King.
And there was a strip already
built in Lake Placid just
nearby.
But their vision of what might
look best in this area was
something like this.
Well, the restrictions in the
map,
the fact that the surveyor and
the other Park Agency employee
had put a pin in this area gave
the State of New York to deny a
permit to this developer simply
based on esthetic grounds.
The developer eventually did
construct a MacDonald's next to
the Wendy's and Burger Kings on
the strip in Lake Placid.
Here's another example of a
developer that proposed a
several-hundred unit condominium
complex on the edge of Lake
Placid.
Lake Placid,
like Lake George,
also provides water from the
lake to its community as their
drinking water source.
And they're very sensitive
about different threats to it,
whether or not it's motorboat
use or whether or not it's new
development on the lakeshore.
This is a very large and
beautiful lake,
and the water quality is
extraordinarily high.
So here you see that part of
this complex is a golf course,
but they wanted to build
hundreds of additional
condominium units.
And the argument that a
developer will make is often
what I call technologically
optimistic.
You know, we can build this
without causing any decline in
water quality within the lake.
We will have the state of the
art sewage treatment system,
we will be sure that no sewage
reaches the lake.
We will also construct our
buildings,
which they wanted on the edge
of the lake,
in a way that would not cause
sediment to flow into the lake
so that there would be no
diminished water clarity.
The water clarity issue is
often a very significant point
of debate with respect to new
development.
In Lake Tahoe,
it's been extremely important
because the clarity of Lake
Tahoe, for those of you that
have been there,
is exceptionally high.
They measure this by a Secchi
disk reading,
which is just a disk that they
drop down into the water.
And you can see that disk in
Lake Tahoe at about fifty feet
in depth, which is really pretty
remarkable.
But gradually,
over several decades,
the visibility declined,
and it was because of
development on the lakeshores.
It was because of sedimentation
and also runoff from adjacent
agricultural uses or say runoff
from streets and roads and
parking lots that were building
up inside the watershed.
So that most communities that
have lakes of extremely high
quality have this concern,
and it justifies their adopting
tougher zoning regulations.
In this case,
when I worked in the
Adirondacks,
I happened to be responsible
for the State of New York's
review of the project and
remember very distinctly the
initial proposal and my response
requesting additional
information that was about a
fifty-page letter that I and
colleagues wrote that we felt we
needed in order to understand
the environmental impacts of
this development on the lake.
Well, the developer decided
that they would scale the
development back quite
substantially.
They wanted a marina,
for example,
that would be suitable for at
least a hundred motorboats.
But the villagers in Lake
Placid didn't want motorboats.
Motors on boats are notoriously
inefficient,
meaning that much of the fuel
is burned but there is a
proportion,
at that point in time,
it was between ten and twelve
percent for the standard engines
that were being used on
motorboats,
is simply shunted into the
water.
So that slicks are common
around marinas that really are
evidence of their inefficiency.
So gradually,
the proposal was whittled back
from several hundred units to
several dozen units.
The developer agreed not to
build the marina.
And he agreed also to put the
buildings back further from the
water to protect it from
sedimentation and protect the
water clarity.
And the total amount of
impervious surface allowed was
also restricted.
So the number of parking
spaces, for example,
or the size of the tract of
land that they owned that could
actually be covered by an
impervious surface.
So these are all regulatory
tools and strategies that could
be used to protect this area.
In addition,
a darker color for the
buildings was required and
building height was restricted.
And this was to protect the
character of the area.
If you were looking at this
site from the middle of Lake
Placid looking back at the
mountain peaks and looking at
the public lands that lie back
here,
it's a very natural looking
landscape,
and that was something that was
protected by the statute.
So that the Adirondack Park
Agency had the authority to say,
"Sorry,
you've got to make sure that
your building is dark in color
and that it's not higher than X
stories."
So that what's really driving
the concern about this is
underlying instincts,
underlying ideologies about
appropriate uses of land and
appropriate definitions of
private property rights,
a libertarian instinct as
opposed to an authoritarian
instinct.
So the longtime residents of
the Adirondacks would march down
the street with the American
flag and argue that their
freedom,
that their liberty was being
violated by this Communist
organization that has taken away
their property rights and not
compensated them.
So the centralization of
authority has been the primary
mechanism of effecting
conservation policy in the
United States.
Taking the private property
rights or assuming authority to
control public lands is a form
of concentration of authority.
Also, the ideology of
utilitarianism,
that these resources are there
for human benefit and human use
and we ought to be allowed to
gain access to them.
We ought to be able to cut down
the timber on Forest Preserve
land.
We ought to be able to ride our
snowmobiles across these trails
that the preservationists'
instincts,
their concern about the noise,
about the air pollution,
their concern about dense
populations in wild areas,
that that was something that
was less important than freedom
of access and the right of the
people to make use of the land.
So, some of the towns already
had a high percentage of
ownership in state lands.
And this created a very
different kind of problem.
So, you know that towns get the
majority of their income from
property taxes.
They get some state subsidies
for a variety of purposes,
including schools,
but also for transportation and
sometimes for medical
facilities.
But a town such as this town
has the majority of its land in
public ownership already,
which means that it has a
highly restricted private tax
base.
So that the State of New York
pays payments in lieu of taxes,
but these really are not
comparable to the kind of income
that could be generated if
development were unregulated,
if they were allowed to build
more rapidly.
Another example of a
conservation strategy is
demonstrated by this case in the
town of Keene.
There is a long strip of land
that's privately owned by the
Sable Club that extends back
perhaps six miles in length and
maybe a half a mile wide.
And I should have a photo here
that would show you that the
sides of these lakes go up quite
dramatically into the
mountainside.
It's owned by a private club.
And the private club decided
that they were going to
self-restrict their development
rights,
but that they were going to
sell those development rights to
the State of New York.
So the State of New York did
not take over complete ownership
of the land.
But remember,
I said that property rights
might be thought of us a bundle.
They sold off the developable
rights to the landscape while
maintaining the underlying fee
ownership.
So that they were able to do
this in a way that reduced their
tax burden.
The tax burden to this
community was substantial,
given the hundreds of acres of
lands that they owned,
so that they were anxious to go
to the town and say,
"Look, our property value
has been diminished,
we've given up our development
rights so that our tax base
should be lowered."
There are a variety of
different instances where the
nature conservancy throughout
the United States has affected
this strategy.
And it's less expensive than
the state going in and buying up
all rights to the land,
and it does offer this benefit
for those that feel like they do
not want to see the area
developed any further.
So in this debate,
as in many debates,
who are the key actors?
Who are the stakeholders that
are common?
Well, there are interesting
tensions between
conservationists and
environmentalists,
particularly in respect to the
intensity of use of public
lands.
So that in the Adirondacks,
for example,
you would have the Adirondack
forty-sixers,
that pride themselves in having
climbed all forty-six peaks in
excess of 4,000 feet in
elevation.
And then you'd have the
environmentalists.
And they were often at odds
about what the right way to
manage public lands ought to be.
There are recreational user
groups, as there are surrounding
all public lands in the United
States.
And these might vary from
cross-country skiers,
to snowmobilers,
to downhill skiers,
to timber companies,
to oil companies,
to those that feel like there
are values associated with those
public lands that they want
access to,
that they can make a profit
from.
There are tourist corporations
as well that always surround
these tracts of land,
outfitters in the western part
of the United States,
horse pack trip offers,
and another good example might
be what happens with the tour
boats and the cruise ships up in
Alaska.
There are also,
as I mentioned earlier,
there are commonly serious
conflicts between permanent
residents that are more anxious
to see additional development of
the park and the seasonal
residents,
that are trying to basically
keep it as undeveloped as
possible.
And there are tensions among
government agencies.
The agency that existed before
the Adirondack Park Agency was
the state's Department of
Environmental Conservation.
And it had authority before the
1973 Act to administer public
lands.
So if you suddenly give that
authority and policy making
responsibility to a different
organization,
you're going to have terrific
resentment on the part of the
agency that formerly had that
authority.
Just like local governments
were resentful about the state
assumption of authority.
And then you have Native
American claims as well that
caused conflict in management of
both private and public lands
and led to litigation in the
park.
Well, we're at time today.
And I'll pick up on public land
issues and also property rights
questions with respect to the
Fifth Amendment on Thursday.
Thank you.